Hello and welcome to my talk on improving low connect
connectivity experiences on the weapon.
I'm Valerie Woolard Srinivasan, I work at
Panoply, the podcast network.
Yes, podcasts, if you want podcast recommendations,
definitely catch me in the hallway later.
But for now, I want to talk a little bit about
the internet.
Also, I have my Twitter handle up here.
Feel free to tweet me your thoughts, favourite
quotes, podcasts, whatever.
I would love to hear from you.
First, let's talk a little bit about the internet.
I love the internet.
We all probably do.
I'm willing to guess that most of us here
have spent plenty of time there, given the
topics of this conference, and are used to
putting it to use for many aspects of our
personal and professional lives.
This is one of my favourite things from the
internet.
It's an owl with a tiny Santa hat on.
But the internet is not just a great place
for finding cute owls with Santa hats, it's
an incredibly important tool.
We are all fans of the internet, and work
with it every day.
We've seen the power and impact that our work
can have.
And wouldn't it be great if that were available
to more people?
While I'm willing to bet that pretty much
everyone in this room has a pretty reliable
high-speed internet connection at home or
work, or, let's be honest, probably both,
that's far from the case for the rest of the
world.
54 per cent of households worldwide have internet
access.
84 per cent of access in developed countries,
and only 15 per cent of households in least
developed countries have access to the internet.
Some of these users may only be able to get
online from a mobile phone network or from
their local library.
Perhaps it goes without saying the more forgiving
your applications or websites are to people
who have slow or limited internet access,
the more people L use them.
Also worth noting the regional and economic
variations in internet accessibility, and
keeping in mind that internet speed could
be a hurdle to people from lower income brackets
or from rural areas using your site.
It makes me think of this quote by William
Gibson: the future is already here, it's just
not very evenly distributed.
As well as being the home for almost all of
the work we as developers do, the internet
has a lot of promise to level disparate tease
caused by difference in class, education,
and access.
In many ways, it is the future.
But just like the future, the internet is
not evenly distributed, either.
We saw in the last slide that there are huge
differences in countries' internet access
due to wealth and infrastructure.
In addition to that, rural households are
less likely to have internet access.
Poorer families are less likely to have internet
access and more than likely to access the
internet on a smartphone rather than a computer.
People with more education are more likely
to access the internet.
Men are more likely than women.
Young people are more likely than older people.
While there is not maybe of we can do for
users who ever access the internet of at all,
there are lots of ways we can help users who
may have limited internet access, and there
are lots of ways that access can be limited.
Let's talk about the different types of ways
people can be internet-limited.
People may fall into multiple of these categories,
and they may not be permanent or applies to
all of the ways that the person accesses the
internet.
First, there's the intermittent connection.
We've all probably experienced this as tried
to use our mobile data network on the train
going between service areas.
This could also be a fixed internet access
point that is unreliable due to service providers
or whenever.
In these cases, the phone or computer may
report it's connected to a network but packets
are not actually being delivered.
Next, there's the slow connection.
That's where reliable connection exists but
it may be much slower than what we are used
to, making it difficult to load websites with
lots of rich content or background scripts.
There's also the bandwidth-limited connection,
which, again we're probably much more familiar
with on our phone but also exists on home
internet plans.
Some users may be limited to a certain number
of gigabytes of data use a month, making them
have a much higher awareness of how much data
they're actually using.
Some people may also have sporadic or time-limited
connections, which I've differentiated from
intermittent connections because they may
be able to predict they could only access
the internet from their local library at a
certain time, or a person who own connects
to the internet in a given time frame.
And may want to cache or save content for
later.
This is the part where I embarrass my mom.
I made her take this picture for me.
It is of her internet satellite dish.
As you might guess, she and my dad lack access
to high-speed internet.
There are no fibre or DSL lines up here.
What there is is a clear view of the Scottish
sky, so they get satellite internet with a
top speed of five megabits per second for
probably than you pay for your cushier plans.
They also have bandwidth caps that caps their
data usage to 10GB a month.
They didn't have any internet access at all
when this picture was taken because their
satellite dish was covered in snow.
During the winter, one of my parents has to
go out and clear it off if they want to keep
using the internet.
Here's a full list of internet plans available
from my parents' provider.
The top download speed is five megabits per
second which is much lower than the 25 required
for the FCC's classification of high speed.
You will also notice that all of the plans
have fairly low bandwidth limits.
You can get all your downloading from midnight
until 5 am.
The limitations of this plan fall into three
of the categories I discussed earlier: it
is slower than we are all used to, it is bandwidth-limited
and time-limited in that it is advantageous
to get your data transfers done in the unlimited
window.
With these constraints in mind, let's continue.
Problems of limited connectivity aren't just
limited to people in rural areas.
Here's a tweet from just a few days ago from
someone visiting Germany who had limited data
speeds.
I think Nicole is at this conference.
And this is from a story that the New York
Times did in August of 2015 entitled, "The
costs of mobile ads on 50 news sites".
It was focusing on the costs of loading these
sites to mobile users, both in terms of literal
cost on their phobe plans, and time spent
waiting for things to load.
As you can see, a lot of the challenges that
apply to mobile internet usage are also relevant
to other limited connectivity users.
It found that most new sites took — news
sites took longer to load ad content than
editorial content.
In some, three times longer.
That means they're waiting three times longer
time for your ad to load than the actual article
that you wanted to read.
Given that these [sound distorted]. ... to
what
the app does, or whether it is added features,
spun or polish.
If the things we are making users load aren't
essential, are we giving them away to opt
out?
Just to illustrate this point a little further
with another recent example, USA Today's European
version of their site got rid of tracking
scripts to comply with GDPR.
As a result, the size of an individual page
went from 5 megabytes to just 500 kilobytes.
Some users don't mind advertising but they
should not have to sacrifice performance in
order to load ads.
So where does that leaves us?
One of the most important things that you
can do to support these types of users is
to build responsive websites.
More and more users are accessing the internet
from mobile phones, and, for many, especially
lower income people, that is the only way
they access the internet.
In addition to being tolerant to flaky networks
as people move in and out of coverage areas,
any website or apps serving these users needs
to be responsive and perform properly on a
small screen and possibly underpowered device.
Another important thing we can do is just
communicate.
Signal and allow people to opt out of high-band
yes, I did portions of your site, from both
a bandwidth and user experience perspective,
there's no reason for you to have an autoplaying
video on your site.
Users should know any time they're about to
download a file, you can use little download
symbols and indicate the file size and possible.
It should be clear to users when they're about
to start playing a video or steam which again
should never autoplay.
Think about how you structure your content.
Remember that sites are loaded top to bottom,
so, by putting important things at the beginning
of your HTML document, those things will load
first allowing users with slow internet to
have something to read before the content
loading.
Place assets or JavaScripts towards the end
if they're not essential to be loaded before
the page renders.
I had to include this because I was adapting
this talk for a European audience, and I know
you like soccer.
I like animals.
This combines the two.
Talking about headers.
Optimise your caching by getting Tam with
what cache headers you're setting, and trying
to avoid users having to refetch content if
it hasn't changed.
Things like fonts, style sheets, other static
assets are examples of things that probably
don't change of over time, and you can improve
your users' experience by not forcing a reload
every time.
Here are some guidelines based on UX research
and attention.
It takes about one second for users to notice
that they're waiting for something to load
and start getting impatient.
It's ideal to have at least some content loaded
after two seconds, even if you can't low the
entire page in that time frame on a slow connection,
it will give the users something to do after
they wait.
After ten seconds, a user will lose interest
and is likely to be divert bid another task.
It should take one minute or less for a user
to complete a simple task on your app, like
signing up or making a purchase.
Longer than that and users will start to perceive
sluggishness.
You can try testing some of these guidelines
and simulating a degraded network environment
and see how long they take on your sites.
I found this recommendation from a UK NGO
from about ten years ago that recommended
an upper limit on page size of 25 kilobytes.
This was based on the connection speeds of
universities and Africa, and the rationale
that such a page would take ten seconds to
load over a 20 kill bits-per-second connection.
As a lot of you have know, this is really
small.
This may not be a realistic guideline for
a lot of people.
It's older and the infrastructure may have
improved, but at the same time, limiting page
size is very important.
In light of that recommendation, let's look
at some of the common libraries we are probably
all using.
jQuery, 85 kilobytes, CSS is another 125.
D3 is 216 kilobytes.
Of course, these are necessary parts of sites
for various reasons, but it is worth being
aware of the costs of these inclusions especially
as we consider these are all before we get
to the size of any of the content on your
website, and the costs of including these
libraries for bandwidth-limited users.
If you're using jQuery for a couple of functions,
maybe consider making that sacrifice.
If you would like to check the sizes of pages
yourself, the network tab on chrome DevTools
can help with profiling this.
If you disable the cache and load a page,
it will give you the total size of data transferred,
and, of course with caching, this is probably
not the amount of data users actually have
to load on every page load, but it can still
give you some idea.
I tried measuring the size of a couple of
of pages.
They were all at least a couple of hundred
kilobytes and plenty went well into the megabytes.
Google page speed insights is another great
resource.
You can take a URL, and it will give suggestions
for how to make that page faster.
The ideas we've talked about so far are helpful
for people with slow internet connections
or limited bandwidth but what about the separate
issue of an unreliable internet connection,
or one that says it is connected but isn't?
There is a growing movement towards offline-first
development, which is that a user does not
have connection and serves from a cache, and,
if there is connection, updated information
can be fetched and rendered.
Of course, it is not magic and only works
if the user has successfully connected before
in order to populate the cache.
But at least it does not assume that they
need a reliable connection every single time.
Email clients are probably the sorts of applications
that we're most familiar with that use this
paradigm.
Even if you're not connected, you can see
the messages downloaded from the last time
you were.
You can even write messages cued up to be
sent next time you have a connection.
Par time is part of progressive web app development
and can be applied to your sites and web apps.
The idea of offline first is helpful to mobile
users and others who cannot predict when they
are offline.
Abdominal additional UI signals, like Google
drive off line, can enable in those scenarios.
Within that research, you will find resources
around offline first and how to start using
it.
I recommend the article designing articles
first web app as a primer on the topic, as
well as resources on how to contribute your
ideas and learn more.
The big idea is that being offline is normal.
And something that should be treated as such,
rather than just throwing an error or exception.
A service worker is now supported on all major
browsers.
It runs as soon as the page is requested,
and before that request is sent out to the
network.
It can serve from a cache if the network is
unavailable.
Service worker introduces a new storage API,
a place to store responses keyed by requests,
similar to the browser cache, but it gives
you a lot more control over what and how content
is cached than a simple browser header.
This can allow you to tell your browser to
cache the pages locally so, if the user loses
a connection, they can still access the site.
If you set up a service worker, you can have
a lot of control how it works.
You can display a custom offline page, similar
to a 404 page, or you can get more created
by having it cache the last couple of articles
that a user has read on your site, or maybe
the most common content that people come to
your site for.
You can also put — use this to put control
back into the users' hands by giving them
sort of UI option to save something for online
— offline use.
Here's Google Chrome's default online page.
You can play a little game with the T. rex
which makes is somewhat less frustrating.
Another useful tool in Google Chrome is that
you can simulate different network conditions
in developer tools, so you can test how your
website or web app looks and performance to
users on different types of connections.
I want to tell you why I think this is important.
In quote is from an unlimited connectivity
users, primarily using a phone, and their
access to new sites.
As you can imagine, as capabilities improved
to make the most complex info graphics, and
most flashy and interactive features, keep
in mind the users that you may be leaving
behind as you make those choices.
It's really easy to always want to be on the
cutting edge, always working in the coolest
technology, but we have to remember that's
all privileged in many places.
That's a quote from Erin Williams from the
Washington Post.
From a pure business perspective, the best
way to reach more customers is to make your
product available and more useful to people.
If your product, welcome site, or app, has
a billion possible users the chances are good
that some are be in the groups that we talked
about earlier —
it's also worth remembering that constant
and reliable internet connectivity is a privilege,
and, by leaving out those who don't have it,
we're leaving out a specific segment of the
population, largely rural, and/or low income.
In the last year, in the United States, we've
been involved in a very heated exchange around
the internet's role in shaping our country,
our politics, and our policies.
As we come to rely on the internet more and
more in our daily lives, both in our logistics
and in our decision-making, we need to be
aware of the consequences that making our
tools and information inaccessible to low
connectivity users has.
Access to legitimate news sources was a huge
issue in the last US election, and one that
is likely to loom large as time goes on.
We looked specifically here at news sites
and the toll that advertising sites can take
on low connectivity users.
If those users aren't able to load legitimate
news sites, then we are in trouble.
If services, applications, or tools are similarly
unavailable to that group, we have a huge
problem.
Think about this and your responsibilities
in this system as you develop websites and
design tools for the future.
I hope that this has given you some more context
and tools for supporting and empathising with
low connectivity users in your development
process.
If nothing else, I hope I've convinced you
never to add an auto playing video to your
website.
I would love to hear more from you.
Again, my name is vein Srinivasan.
If you're interested in podcasts, programming,
and living in the Washington, DC area, I would
love to talk about roles at Panopoly, or we
can talk about our favourite podcast.
Thank you for having me.
I will be posting these slides on my Twitter
feed and providing links to citations and
more resources.
[Applause].
>> Thank you so much, Valerie.
Having grown up in a developing country, I
find this topic incredibly important.
Our next speaker is so special that we are
going to take a few minute to set her up because
she brought props.
Talk amongst yourselves, and we will get started
in two minutes.
>> Hello.
We're doing a lit of an MC hand-off here.
I'm Rachel.
I'm looking forward to introducing receive
knee for this upcoming talk.
She's a really cool person.
But I will introduce myself first, because
Stephanie has still got a few moments left
to go, and I think of myself as my favourite
person!
So, I'm Rachel Neighbours, I hail from the
United States of America, recently moved to
Amsterdam.
That's where Stephanie is also from.
She's a pretty cool person too.
What I love most about Amsterdam is that it
has got a really funky creator-tech community,
of which Stephanie is a member.
But in the United States, I'm mostly known
for working with web animations.
I wrote a book about it.
Basically filling air until we're ready to
get going.
I know some people are changing their conference
venue right now.
What else do we have?